Final Fantasy 7 remake features a hybrid
gameplay system that merges real-time
action with strategic command based
combat for starters each press of the
square button is a swing of clouds
Buster Sword cloud attacks dodges and
blocks all in real time the standard
attacks do some damage but they barely
scratched the surface of clouds true
potential succeeding on the battlefield
requires much more than just hacking and
slashing cloud needs to be tactical he
needs a tea fee to ATP bars are
displayed in the lower right please fill
up slowly over time but fill much faster
as cloud lands standard attacks once an
ATV bar is full you can enter tactical
mode where time slows to a crawl and you
have the opportunity to choose actions
from the commitment command menu katashi
Sun I've had the pleasure of seeing
quite a bit of the game but tactical
mode never gets old for me I could just
sit here all day long and watch this
beautiful slow motion action contacted
us and they were sort of good everyone
was pushing me time of the night the
police got me nothing guys I think the
audience would like to see more isn't
that right everyone
good point good point well what's in
tactical mode you can choose to perform
various abilities such as clouds' braver
attack using an item in battle will
deplete an ATV charge and if cloud has
the right materia and enough MP he can
use a DB charges to cast spells of
course this being a remake we're sure to
see some familiar faces with the use of
this iconic gun arm Baird is able to
target enemies at a distance
Barrett standard attacks generate ATP
charges similar to cloud but his
abilities are entirely different
switching between characters and combat
is done with a single button press which
makes rotating through party members a
snap speaking of other party members
ketosis on what are we going to see Tifa
action alright can continue to fight
even when you're not controlling them
directly but it's up to you to choose
how and when HEV charges are used you
can maximize your effectiveness by
switching between characters or issuing
commands to characters with full ATV
bars
every enemy has a focus gauge that fills
up as you do damage when the gauge is
full the enemy becomes staggered and
you'll deal bonus damage tactical mode
evokes the command selections from the
original Final Fantasy 7 and allows
players to enjoy battle while taking the
time to think strategically for players
who prefer fast-paced action abilities
and spells can be bound to shortcuts for
immediate execution shortcuts make
combat extremely dynamic but the choice
of using them is entirely up to you
Raika tosses on today's Tanya Isaiah
Thomas emitter gave me nothing personal
bit did you take it off site that's
right the game has been made so that you
can choose how to play I hopefully ours
get excited about this classic brief
introduction to combat in Final Fantasy
7 remake and we look forward to showing
you a whole lot more in the coming
months for now let's see how clouded
Barrett do against a more formidable foe
[Music]
reinforced armor plated with the
internal steel
lightning magic
[Music]
it's on you yes it's mine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a barrier
what you're drilling
[Music]
[Music]
focused on that core
[Music]
take them down
[Music]
dammit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
taking over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you hear that damn thing show you how
it's done
[Applause]